he was extremely traumatic extremely
shocking a society of complete chaos
rampant crime
can you unpack for us why
contrary to what we might expect the
anti-democratic Putin actually enjoys
not perhaps popularity but amazingly
strong support among many Russians
[Music]
well uh I I was probably going to begin
my answer by asking you a question uh
what do you think of when I say the word
democracy
uh are people who are in the end able to
dictate to government
what it is uh that they want and to
remove them peacefully if they don't
deliver and with that kind of a pencil
Prosperity yeah stability security and
many other things whilst people remain
true to the ideals of democracy and
understand its foundations
well we can get into that conversation
separately but if we stick with with
answer to your initial question is when
you think of democracy you think about
the ability to remove a leader
peacefully transition of power security
stability and prosperity that's why we
all think democracy is great if you say
democracy to a Russian person well
you've got to look at our history we've
never had democracy Russia has never had
Russia the first uh mention historically
of Russia is eight eight eighty two
um so 12 1200 years ago a long time ago
in that entire period there's never been
a single democratic transition of power
ever
ever yeah the only time Russia
experimented with quote-unquote
democracy and for people listening I'm
using quotation marks was the period
between 1991 yeah and the period in 1999
When Vladimir Putin becomes prime
minister and eventually president
that period is probably one of the most
traumatic periods in the history of
anyone alive in Russia today it was a
time in which uh you went from a poor
and unfree society which was the Soviet
Union which most people didn't really
know how poor and how unfree they were
to a society of complete chaos rampant
crime uh you went from you know you were
a university Professor with a
respectable job and and today and
tomorrow and I mean tomorrow you were
selling your belongings in the street
your children who were in school and
doing well and all you all they needed
to do was get the right grades and go to
the right University and then they would
have a career it wouldn't be a great
career but it would be one that would
their life would be okay suddenly your
son was sent shipped off to find
chechnya which you'd never heard of
before and your daughter was a
prostitute because that was how quickly
the society changed I'm not saying that
was every single person's experience but
we all knew somebody we all knew
somebody who'd Fallen a woman had fallen
prayed to the slave trade or a person
who you know lost a son in chechnya or
was wounded or was sent to the military
uh or someone who ended up going from
being wealthy to being in extreme
poverty people who drank themselves to
death people who took drugs and and
overdosed on drugs we all and the thing
that was most important about that he
was through note fault of your own the
society collapsed around you and
everything you'd worked for all your
savings gone overnight gone
think about that yeah think how shocking
that is to people it's very hard to come
to groups with yeah it's hard to imagine
people will listen to this and go oh but
you can't imagine it everything in your
life think about your life now your
family your friends your finances how
much money you have your job all of that
gone through no fault of your own
you've done nothing wrong but the
society has collapsed
and suddenly it's chaos and you are not
prepared for this Market capitalist
Society you were told all your life be a
good Soviet citizen go to school go to
university do your job do what you're
told and you did and you had a decent
life and suddenly all of that's over
right it was extremely traumatic
extremely shocking and Vladimir Putin is
widely seen in Russia as the person who
ended that chaos he comes in he ends the
one chechnya he deals with the threat of
terrorism
he stabilizes the country economically
mainly because oil prices are extremely
high and so he's able to share some of
that wealth with the people and so yes
of course and also importantly as well
he stabilizes the country by
nationalizing the crime and Corruption
crime and Corruption doesn't end it just
becomes controlled and it is exercised
through the state he is the person who
is the chief oligarch and he has other
oligarchs under him who are all
appointed they're all appointed there is
no such thing as an independent uh there
is no real private property at that
level in Russia if you're a billionaire
you're not really a billionaire you're a
billionaire as long as you are faithful
to the regime right so it's controlled
that rampant sort of uh capitalism
exploitative capitalism that we saw in
the 90s is over in Russia it's
controlled it's nationalized so he's
widely seen as having brought stability
and the worst of it is John is that this
layers on top
Russian history in which every time
there's been instability of some kind or
almost every time
what happens is a foreign Invasion some
kind of deep deep social uh Discord
Strife Etc there's a period in Russian
history called times of trouble and this
is the thing every child has taught
about at school and this this was the
time the the polls and the lithuanians
whoever it was came and and took over
our country and humiliated us and we
these great people were under the Boo
and before that we were under the
Mongols and Russian history is all about
these periods of chaos and instability
in which some external Force comes in
and ruins us and all it takes is a
strong leader who's going to come in
stabilize things and take control so if
the only thing in your mind when you
hear the word democracy is the 1990s
why on Earth would you want to go back
there
foreign
ly your son was sent shipped off to fire
in chechnya which you'd never heard of
before and your daughter was a
prostitute because that was how quickly
the society changed